[Music]
right here's one man at the very top of
this ongoing Russia collusion witch-hunt
now after Attorney General Jeff Sessions
recused himself from all things Russia
well the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein assumed the responsibility
now this despite having massive
conflicts of interest remember was rod
Rosenstein who drafted a report
detailing why James Comey should be
fired
it was rod Rosen Stein who signed off on
the third FISA renewal application the
fourth FISA warrant against Trump
campaign associate Carter page and of
course all of this as the Nunez memo and
the Grassley gram memo says the bulk of
information came from that phony Russian
dossier that Hillary paid for the dirty
dossier with Russian lies now for months
we have literally been shouting from a
mountaintop matter of fact well over a
year now that this whole process he is
and has been corrupt nobody in this
equation can be trusted tonight and now
we have confirmation New York Times
reporting today adoring meetings with
top DOJ FBI officials including Lisa
Paige and Andrew McCabe who was a known
liar we know that a grand jury has been
convened in his case rod Rosenstein
actually planned to push a quote
according to the New York Times secret
secretly record the President of the
United States in the White House to
expose the chaos consuming the
administration and disgust recruiting
cabinet members to invoke the 25th
amendment so they would remove President
Trump your duly elected president from
office for quote being unfit now this
all allegedly took place during Rosen
Stein's second week on the job this is
right after President Trump fired Comey
based on rod Rosen Stein's
recommendation in part and by the way
under article 2 of our Constitution he
didn't even have to like James Comey
shoes and he could have fired him for
that and according to The Times Rosen
Stein thought quote well he might be
able to persuade the Attorney General
jeff Sessions General Kelly then the
Secretary of Homeland Security now the
White House chief of staff to mount an
effort to invoke the 25th amendment two
weeks into the job Rod Rosenstein wanted
to wear a wire secretly record a scene
President of the United States in vocht
the 25th amendment in other words a
silent coup against his boss by him
McCabe others all against a duly elected
president we are experiencing tonight a
massive constitutional crisis and
frankly this is designed to set up the
president I'll explain what this is
about in a minute now tonight rod
Rosenstein he is publicly denying this
report calling the story inaccurate
factually inaccurate he wrote quote I
never pursued or authorized recording
the president any suggestion that I have
ever advocated for the removal of the
president is absolutely false given the
numerous sources in this story the New
York Times remains adamant in their
reporting two of their sources by the
way we know one is Andrew McCabe and
another is Lisa Paige
although Lisa page not on the 25th
amendment side of this and we do know
McCabe's a known liar but we have other
sources tonight telling Fox News that
rod Rosen Stein's remarks were made
sarcastically but the New York Times
they are standing behind the story and
the seriousness of rod Rosen Stein's
remarks let's take a look it's like on
that flip put the remark and he was in
fact very serious and the circumstances
in which he was described to me are
different now than what's being put out
I guess by the government but I you know
it's important that your listeners
understand something that as I was
pursuing this story for a very long time
people reluctant to talk about it
because of the gravity of the story that
there was concern that if they got out
that you know Rosenstein Rosen Stein had
wanted to actually you know wear a wire
I suggested McCann D became the deputy
director the acting director at the time
wear a wire that rod might get fired
people were sincerely concerned about
this not because he made a flip remark
because of the seriousness around these
the remark so rod Rosenstein well the
New York Times is standing by their
story Andrew McCabe is one of the
sources his lawyer admitted that today
and he is saying a known liar now that
in fact rod meant what he said we're
going to have a lot more information
from the New York Times report
throughout the hour tonight out before
appointing Muller to lead the Special
Counsel investigation Rosenstein floated
another candidate we find out from the
New York Times his name is James and
Cole
well that's problematic because Cole
while he was a Deputy Attorney General
under Obama conflict enough he was also
the private lawyer to Sid Sid Vicious
Blumenthal that's Clinton's personal
political hitman and as you can see
neither rod Rosenstein Andrew McCabe
Lisa Paige Peter struck James Comey
Bruce or is a friend of the President
that's why this country is in crisis
tonight their bias is all obvious here
this has been corrupt from the beginning
before the election after the election
they wanted to take down Donald Trump
now it's time tonight for the Attorney
General to now do his job mr. sessions
this is your Department of Justice under
no circumstances I have a message for
the president tonight under 0
circumstances should the president fire
anybody these actors tonight and I've
have multiple sources confirming this
and more information coming they are
hoping and praying that the President
does just that they're hoping he gets
mad that he gets sick and tired of it
and that they can turn this politically
into their equivalent of a Friday night
massacre the president needs to know it
is all a setup he needs to know that
regardless of whether he steps in or not
and I would argue he should definitely
not the deep State tonight is crumbling
from within at this very hour they're
now turning against each other it's the
president's job and duty of course to
remove all enemies from within but of
course Democratic Senator Chuck Schumer
is in meltdown mode you would think they
cared about the truth you think they
would care about fixing and rigging and
attempting to rig elections and lying to
the American people and propagandizing
the American people of misinforming the
American people and having real Russian
information bought and paid for by one
party to destroy another candidate and
that FISA Court judges were all lied to
but Chuckie doesn't care about that at
all they only cares about his friends in
the
deep state and tonight he released a
statement that proves just that this
story must not be used as a pretext for
the corrupt purpose of firing the Deputy
Attorney General Rosenstein in order to
install an official who allow the
president interfere with the special
counsels investigation generals Kelly
mattis and numerous other White House
and cabinet officials have been reported
to say critical things of the president
without being fired hey Chuck none of
them have talked about literally trying
to set up a president and tape-recorder
president and invoke the 25th amendment
Chuck of course we know what would
happen if Rosen Stein and others are
fired by Jeff Sessions Jeff sessions
actually has that's his department Jeff
Sessions where are you tonight Solicitor
General Noel Francisco would likely take
over rod Rosen Stein's Russia duties and
he worked in the DOJ and the president
george w bush he clerked for Antonin
Scalia more importantly he doesn't have
the baggage the conflicts of interest or
we've apparently the anti-trump bias
that so many others have had from the
beginning but with that said I don't
know at this hour who to trust anymore
in the FBI or the DOJ well I do the
rank-and-file the people that do their
job in the field offices every day I
trust them those that are upset about
this the most corrupt massive abuse of
power in this country's history I
believe in them they are as upset
rightly so is what we all are I mean
while this story is now shining a new
light on the president's decision Monday
to declassify FISA documents 302s other
important information related to the FBI
DOJ handling of this so-called Russia
objective probe today the president
tweeted out quote I met with the DOJ
concerning the declassification of
various unredacted documents they agreed
to release them but stated that so doing
may have perceived negative impact on
the Russian
what allies what countries they called
to ask not to release them therefore the
Inspector General has been asked to
review these documents on an expedited
basis I believe you will move quickly on
this and hopefully
things which he's looking at meaning
FISA in the end I can still always
declassify it if it proves necessary
speed is very important to me and to
everyone other allies there has been a
lot of chatter do we have allied
countries we have a Fourth Amendment
protection against unreasonable search
and seizure against using wiretapping
against American citizens is it possible
some of their friends in other countries
might be thinking tonight that they're
going to be exposed for doing the dirty
work sharing the information that they
got that would otherwise be gotten
illegally in this country with some of
our deep state actors it raises a lot of
questions tonight these documents the
president requested Monday must be
released must be Declassified
immediately this same routine has played
out well over a year now about two years
we have the DOJ deep state actors have
done everything in their power including
lie that this will impact sources and
methods when it doesn't to prevent them
from releasing the information that we
the American people deserve to see these
actors know they will be exposed their
corruption the serious misconduct
McCabe struck page and perhaps even
James Comey himself the DOJ has delayed
delayed delayed the release of these
important documents over again and again
they have defied congressional subpoenas
obstructed justice at this point defied
the oversight constitutional authority
of Congress the president cannot let
this go on any longer because as we wait
the deep state is winning and they're
trying to set up traps even for the
President himself these documents must
be made available to you the American
people with spartacus cory booker when
we need them we deserve full
transparency for the american people
no more delaying no more hiding no more
lying no more obstructing you we the
people deserve to know what these top
upper-level people in our government
were doing to undermine the people's
pick for president the damning
revelations today surrounding rod
Rosenstein well it's not the only time
that the
State has been caught trying to sabotage
President Trump far from it let's look
at this timeline we put together let's
start in 2015 the FBI opening a criminal
investigation into Hillary Clinton
we know she violated the law committed
multiple felonies miss handling
top-secret classified special access
program information on her private email
server in a mom-and-pop shop bathroom
and in a very rare move the FBI director
James Comey he rips the case away from
our honorable FBI field agents the guys
we trust he took it in-house politicized
it himself with of course the help of
Andrew McCabe Peter struck and others
then they put the fix in just by
overwhelming evidence of guilt they end
up exonerating Hillary Clinton oh they
were writing that exoneration in May of
2016
they never interviewed her or 17 other
key witnesses until July and then
remember it was struck and Comey they
worked on the draft in May before the
July exoneration well they were changing
it from the you know gross negligence
legal term to the more innocuous just
careless just like sandy Berger goes
steals documents puts them in his pants
his socks frankly on his backside walks
out and says oh I'm just being sloppy
really people put documents private
documents and their pants and then
sloppy meanwhile the very same time the
Clinton campaign along with the DNC
funneling money through a law firm oh
you mean it wasn't a legal expense then
they hire fusion GPS to do op research
who hired an ex foreign spy I thought
they weren't supposed to influence our
elections his name is Christopher steel
and the wife of course of a high-ranking
DOJ official Nellie or to put together a
campaign op research document a series
of documents that then became known as
the dossier all against Donald Trump
filled with salacious lies and rumors
never verified never corroborated none
of it neither Steele himself said I
don't know if any of this is true maybe
5050 in an interrogatory in Great
Britain that dossier was spread
throughout the highest levels of our
federal government all these
beep state actors by Nellie ORS husband
who became the conduit for Christopher
steel Bruce or the fourth highest
ranking official at the DOJ that dossier
was leaked to the press why to lie to
you the American people and influence an
election to help Hillary just kind of
like what she did to Bernie it was used
as the basis of the FISA warrants
against the Trump campaign associate
Carter Paige signed off on by multiple
officials including Comey including
McCabe
including Yates and rod Rosen Stein
himself and after the election the
dossier was then used again as the basis
the fundamental basis for what we now
know to be molars witch-hunt or even
brief Muller deputy Andrew Weissman this
made its way right into Special Counsel
ballerz office Andrew Weissman Mulder's
pit bull he got the contents of that
dossier right from Hillary to steal from
russia with love to robert Muller's
office all in an effort to take down the
president you elected all right we have
a lot more throughout the show tonight
but we have other top breaking news
tonight now for a week the Republicans
rightly so they have tried to
accommodate in every way imaginable
judge Cavanaugh's accuser professor
Christine Ford clearly one of her
liberal lawyers Deborah Katz and Senator
Dianne Feinstein are playing politics
and the sad thing is this is such a
serious accusation it should be handled
in a nonpartisan way it should be
pursued just for the sake of pursuing
truth and justice and as Susan Collins
has said and she is absolutely right
it's unfair what Dianne Feinstein and
others have been doing I have sources
tonight telling me the professor's
Ford's attorney keep moving the bar all
over the place at this hour no deal has
been struck with Professor Ford's
attorney to testify
senator Grassley finally has had to
extend yet again the deadline now it's
10:00 p.m. tonight and Senator Grassley
released a statement earlier this is
what it reads quote despite the fact
that the July 30th letter remains hidden
my committee has been
stating the allegations and has heard
from multiple witnesses since Sunday Ms
Katz has discussed dr. Ford's
allegations and numerous media
interviews and said on TV Monday morning
that dr. Ford wants to share her account
with the Senate Judiciary Committee all
right it's Friday night nothing's been
agreed to despite our extensive efforts
to make testimony possible I'm extending
the deadline for response yet again to
10:00 o'clock this evening on providing
a notice of a vote to occur Monday in
the event that dr. Ford's attorney
doesn't respond Oh dr. Ford Assad
tonight to testify in the event we can
come to a reasonable resolution as I
have been seeking all week
then I will postpone the committee vote
to accommodate her testimony we cannot
continue to delay senator Grassley has
been gracious rightly so and
accommodating in multiple ways if her
lawyers keep moving the goalposts and
they don't give answers and they keep
making new demands and they don't show
up
what are lawmakers to do and by the way
isn't it really unfair for the accuser
to be heard literally after the accused
no I think the accusers should have the
right to respond to the accusations that
are made senators Grassley and Graham
said they will not concede that point
and also tonight my sources are telling
me that the conclusion of many
Republican lawmakers is that Professor
Ford's liberal attorney this is not in
any way I want
professor Ford to be heard I want her
story told in in a fair manner she's
been offered all sorts of opportunities
in private in public
they'll come to her she doesn't have to
ever go before a television camera but
her attorney has adopted a strategy
obviously it's called running out the
clock and by the way the Republicans see
them for what it is to blame the GOP for
not making proper accommodations when
they have done just the opposite
it shouldn't surprise anyone that
Republicans think this after all this
lawyer Deborah Katz is highly partisan
longtime democratic active
tens of thousands of dollars in donation
clearly has a political agenda her views
on sexual assault and misconduct
allegations have been inconsistent to
put it mildly here are a few examples of
what I mean she said about Paul Jones
quote her suit is very very weak she's
alleged one incident that took place in
a hotel room that by her own testimony
lasted 10 to 12 minutes
she suffered no repercussions in the
workplace she then said of Jones
accusations quote clearly a one-time
incident that took place in 10 to 12
minutes she was not forced to have sex
she left of her own volition the courts
increasingly are finding that is not
enough to create a sexually hostile work
environment claim then she defended
creepy senator Al Franken context is
relevant well he did not do this as a
member of the Senate he did this in the
capacity of someone who was still
functioning as an entertainer
excuse me Al Franken was a senator when
this in fact occurred
that's issue 1 issue 2 we're gonna talk
about what it is Bill Clinton did to
Paula Jones he dropped his pants exposed
himself to a woman he didn't know and
said kiss it now Paula Jones won a
settlement agreement eight hundred and
fifty thousand dollars but the point
here is the lawyer professor Ford well
clearly she has a political agenda
inconsistent views on this topic Daily
Caller today uncovered that back in 2017
the same lawyer she vowed to resist get
this president Trump take a look for
yourself finally over the finish line
the new Attorney General this morning
grateful to the colleagues who fought
for him I can't express how appreciative
I am for those of you who stood by me
during this difficult time
it was a bitter feud to the very end
we're gonna fight that we are going to
resist we will not decide that's her
resisting now why does this attorney
keep moving the goalposts for an
interview on Monday Kat said Professor
Ford would be willing to testify and do
it publicly and under oath then the
man's they start continued changing all
throughout the week making it almost
impossible for for professor Ford's
allegation to be heard she does deserve
to be heard and tonight things have even
gotten worse senator Feinstein who has
been delaying and obstructing why hasn't
senator Feinstein turned over the full
letter to Republican senators on the
Judiciary Committee like Grassley now
Feinstein knew about this allegation
back in July it's September
senator Feinstein never bothered to
raise any of these allegations with
Judge Cavanaugh privately or in public
hearings even though there were numerous
opportunities for her to do so instead
the Democrats they've now turned this
into a political circus we saw it at the
hearings they have rushed to convict
judge Cavanaugh without even a hearing
not hearing either side of their story
and Dianne Feinstein took it to the next
level tonight after all the
accommodations offered by the
Republicans and Charles Grassley and the
president being accommodating on his
hand saying he wants her to be heard
well it was entitled by the way
Feinstein on Republican bullying of
sexual assault survivor well obviously
there's no point in her having a hearing
she's already decided who's guilty who's
believable and who was not they're all
free to speak with her and listen to
what Democratic senator Whitehouse had
to say just yesterday listen to this if
the Democrats win back the house and or
the Senate Democrats will investigate
what happened the charges of Professor
Ford is laying out even if that means
investigating a Supreme Court justice at
the time I am confident of that and I
think we'll also be investigating why
the FBI stood down its background
investigation when this case
up in this particular background another
senator that's made up her mind of
senator Kristin Gillibrand of New York
she said she believed Cavanaugh's
accusers she's made up her mind quote
denying doctor Ford an FBI investigation
is silencing her
no the FBI senator said it is not in
their purview to have there's no crimes
within their jurisdiction forcing her
get this forcing her into a sham hearing
now senator Gillibrand made up her mind
she says it's silencing her to offer a
hearing and pushing Brett Kavanaugh is
conferring confirmation through if you
allow in every single accommodation
private not private will go to you you
can come to us moving the days and dates
and then the person doesn't want to talk
that was the right thing to do by the
Republicans but offering a platform to
tell your story is not silencing
somebody and unfortunately that's not
all Democrats are convicting judge
Cavanaugh before even any side has been
heard forget about due process forget
about the presumption of innocence take
a look the Senate shouldn't simply rely
on hearing two conflicting accounts and
decide well we're okay with not knowing
we're okay with the fact that we might
be putting a someone who committed
attempted rape on the Supreme Court the
United States I believe her listen first
of all anybody who comes forward at this
point to be prepared to testify in the
United States Senate against someone
who's being nominated to one of the most
powerful positions in the United States
government that takes an extraordinary
amount of courage not only do women like
dr. Ford who bravely comes forward need
to be heard but they need to be believed
they need to be believed I just want to
say to the men in this country just shut
up and step up do the right thing let me
just say right at the outset I believe
dr. Ford I believe the survivor here
there's every reason to believe her she
has come forward courageously and
bravely I believe
I stand with her and hope she shows up
on Monday do you hope that she should be
bullied into this scenario where it's a
he-said she-said it's a sham hearing and
I don't think she should participate in
it I believe professor Ford
I think she's credible and I think when
the investigation is finished and when
she testifies and judge Kavanagh
testifies I think a majority of senators
will find her credible and I don't think
I didn't ever thought Kavanagh should
get get appointed all of these Democrats
say they believe her they've already
made up their minds interesting
interestingly that's the Republicans
that are being fair and open and
offering opportunities for both sides to
be heard did you imagine if Republicans
came out one after another they believe
judge Kavanagh they'd be eviscerated
tonight the double standard is so
blatantly obvious where's all the
outrage from the left about the
allegations made against Democratic
congressman keith Ellison this past
month in August accused of his
girlfriend longtime girlfriend of
repeated domestic and verbal abuse this
is the bottom line what is happening
right now is not fair to Professor Ford
it is not fair to judge Cavanaugh the
allegations are serious this shouldn't
be about politics and rushing to
judgment and no due process and no
presumption of innocence this should not
be about hiding letters and lawyers not
getting back to a Senate committee after
so much accommodation this should be
about getting to the truth and this
should be about justice this should be
about putting good people on the Supreme
Court this is too serious and allegation
too serious an issue to be playing
politics now the families of Judge
Cavanaugh professor Ford they're all
receiving death threats which needs to
stop enough already
this is becoming a sick twisted ugly
partisan you know one side cares about
only one side power that's why in 46
days this election matters on so many
levels